soy dave cum y soy el director ejecutivo
de perth que es el proyecto para la
investigación educativa escalable por
sus siglas en inglés y es un centro de
la universidad de stanford verds realiza
una serie de recursos para ayudar a los
educadores a aprender sobre la ciencia
de la motivación y hacemos esto con la
intención de ayudarlos a inspirar a
todos los estudiantes a aprender sin
miedo cuando los estudiantes tienen una
mentalidad de crecimiento cuando piensan
dentro de una mentalidad de crecimiento
realmente están pensando en sus
habilidades como algo que pueden hacer
crecer como un músculo algo que pueden
aumentar con el tiempo si invierten sus
esfuerzos en la estrategia correcta
cuando los estudiantes piensan dentro de
una mentalidad fija tienden a pensar en
sus habilidades como algo fijo como el
color de los ojos algo de ellos mismos
que realmente no pueden cambiar cuando
los estudiantes tienen una mentalidad de
crecimiento creo que hacen dos cosas que
son realmente útiles
que a la larga les ayudarán a ser más
exitosos y estar más motivados una es
que bien los desafíos como una
oportunidad de aumentar sus habilidades
esto significa que es menos probable que
se desanimen si se encuentran con algo
que representa un reto en contraste es
más probable que busquen desafíos y las
investigaciones muestran que de hecho
cuando los estudiantes tienen una
mentalidad de crecimiento hay más
probabilidades de que busquen trabajos
que representen retos
la otra cosa es que se dan cuenta de que
si realmente se llega natural en algo la
clave para resolverlo puede ser uno
perseverar pero 2 igual de importante
cambiar la estrategia que estén
utilizando quizá a buscar ayuda de
alguien más y si tienen una mentalidad
de crecimiento es menos probable que les
preocupe que pedir ayuda
signifique que no son lo suficientemente
inteligentes como para tener éxito por
el contrario ellos entenderán que sus
maestros y compañeros los pueden ayudar
a crecer ya
desarrollarse como estudiantes mediante
las actividades de campeonato intentamos
armar a los maestros con muchas
actividades para que ellos y sus
estudiantes aprendan juntos sobre la
ciencia del aprendizaje y la ciencia de
la mentalidad de crecimiento también los
ayudarán a participar en formas
importantes de autorreflexión y en
diferentes tipos de actividades que
reforzarán esas ideas en el transcurso
de campeonato y también a crear un
modelo un andamiaje y un acercamiento
hacia la autorreflexión a pensar en el
aprendizaje y en la mentalidad de
crecimiento esto puede revisarse a lo
largo del año para reforzar estas ideas
y para recordarles a los estudiantes que
continúen que sigan creciendo